maybe this can be like our tradition  moving forward is just like our local  family this is like right below eating  glazed ham for me  [Music]  dojo  no longer need the person with the long  arm that was the guy right it's always  like oh sorry long arm guy that thing  shot where his face is extra close now  boom you just put it in the center of  the living room everyone's in the shot  did any of you guys have your family pet  in the Christmas card my dog can only  like see his back he's never faced the  camera my mom used to take me and my  brother to the Santa at the mall for a  couple years it was the only thing that  we agreed on we didn't want to do that  three two one  jeez  [Music]  you